[Music]
I can breathe again 12 years a slave is
directed by Steve McQueen and stars she
weds eligio for I really tried with that
name I really did probably got it wrong
because I'm a stupid American also stars
Michael Fassbender Benedict Cumberbatch
Brad Pitt as well as others lots of big
names in this movie this movie's a true
story of a man who was sold into slavery
when he was free and the perils that
become of that and you really get a
lynching look at slavery and the way
that it was back then to the point where
you start to hate yourself as a human
being you watch this movie in it's just
amazing how barbaric people used to be
and it's so enthralling at the same time
to watch this man go through such a
struggle and the journey that he takes
the people that he meets and the way
this film goes about telling his story
well the best movies of the year
definitely as a director Steve McQueen I
think is totally brilliant he has
incredible shots in his movies I mean
the framing that he uses is remarkable
the lighting is so good he has extremely
long takes we were just watching them
with your eyes just like the shot is
still going on and it's so effective
I loved hunger which was his debut movie
with Michael Fassbender as the starving
prisoner shame also with Michael
Fassbender great movie 12 years of slave
probably his best movie definitely
actually his best movie she where Lee Jo
for gives such a good performance in
this movie where you feel so much for
him as a character he wants so much for
him to succeed and you want him to be
able to get back to his normal life but
it's also not the type of performance
that's like look at me look at me I'm an
actor because you can easily look at
this movie and be like this is just
total Oscar bait it doesn't really come
off that way though it really feels
unflinchingly real in the best type of
way where you're watching the movie and
you just feel like you are in the moment
like I was in the theatre for over two
hours feeling like I was in the nastiest
place you could possibly be and I felt
like I was there Michael Fassbender in
this movie Wow
hugely great performance I mean this guy
knocks it out of the park because I've
always liked him as an actor but you
watch this movie and this is the first
time you've ever seen him as a character
where you just think this is the worst
man
planet and he just owns this role
because he is the guy who prides himself
in breaking these slaves let's say you
pick 300 pounds of cotton yesterday and
today you pick 299 they're getting
lashes that's how much of a satanic
barbaric individual this guy is and
Michael Fassbender is so good in this
movie he's so terrific his wife in the
movie just as bad and so you get to
watch this character deal with this and
he meets certain people that are willing
to help and that lend a sympathetic ear
like Brad Pitt's character but for the
most part you just like oh oh my god
this is a good movie but I can't deal
with this right now it's so depressing
but it's also uplifting at the same time
I gotta say there are two shots in this
movie I won't spoil them - the best
shots of the year it's this one shot
that just does not end and you're just
watching it like this is so horrible but
my mouth was dropped at just how great
that shot was because you're watching
and thinking isn't someone gonna do
something and it's just so well done the
second shot is this moving all around so
many things happen in one shot with
characters doing so many things and
you're thinking wow the time that it
took to set up this shot it's so
brilliant 12 years a slave is an
excellent movie my only flaws with it is
that perhaps it's a little too long
that's it this is a terrific movie and
if you love film you should probably
experience this movie at least once in
your life I think it's excellent one of
the best of the year I'm gonna give it a
name guys thanks as always very much for
watching and if you liked this you can
click right here and get stuck menage
[Music]